i really like backpacks
right now we are doing these backpacks
and i wearing this one i really like it
we decided to call the backpack freedom
and in swahili guru means freedom and we
decided to
name the backpack forum
do
i got an education as a medical staff
and i was a cardiac surgeon
in 2014
someone presented me the backpack i got
a few trips i was with this backpack and
got a severe weather conditions
and
all of my belongings was injured i mean
that they completely wetted and did my
passport the documents and once i backed
here to ukraine i decided to
create a
completely different backpack with
really good looking
with the durable
i started the research of the
main niche backpack manufacturers in the
whole of the world i bought a few of
them and
started to find the good team to make my
dream come true
i met our present constructor and main
designer italy with him we did the first
model of her
backpack
[Music]
we are producing around 250 backpacks
per month and we are exporting 53
countries the main idea was make the the
brand globalized not only here located
in ukraine we started to think about how
can we spread of this product in the in
the world and the start of the project
was actually with kickstarter it was
successful and it was really really good
[Music]
we are doing the backpack with the high
quality materials we are using our
philosophy in a style of the backpack
the first model which we did too it was
only for the tremolo right now it's
presented five models
four of them mostly for the travel and
for the city
we are planning to start producing the
clothes
this is a hero a model this is a third
model of for the line of uhuru
all of uh backpacks you're gonna open
the the main compartment here
you can find the the main compartment
with sewing inside organizer if you get
a more
clothes or more stuff you can
open the bottom of the backpack and your
backpack from 25 liters and expect for
five more liters
we are doing a lot of stuff to protect
the safety for example the access for
the laptops you have to open this stuff
and then you have to open the deeper and
then you can find the
the access to the laptop then you can
find the
uh
back pocket for myself and mostly use
this this pocket for the passport or
some
valuable stuff then
the few more pockets in the front credit
cards again keys so you can put it to
the fastest access if you require this
we are doing all of the goods in the
point that all of accessories all of
stuff we are producing they have to fit
to each other in any case it's our
messenger a lot of backpack
manufacturers they're doing their own
belt for the backpack to keep the bag
more closely for the backpack and
for this one we decided that we can do
it versatile and created a fanny pack
you can use it by your own for keep some
goods
in and into another way you can put it
in the back of the backpack and
you can use it as a belt
so the second backpack is
it's our iconic backpack one of the best
selling backpack actually h2 model this
one mostly for the city i can use
daily or for example 2-3 working days in
a travel
and the third model that
for s model 16 liter volume it's
completely for the city for the work for
the walk-in
for all of our backpacks we are given
lifetime warranty we are producing this
serial number for each backpack and we
are following all of the customers so
once
the client got a backpack in any case if
he got some injured or he has to fix
something
he can send this
through the email we are
taking this backpack and given to the
manufacturing the fixing in the
beginning of the brand
we didn't get any
problems with the customers about this
service of lifetime warranty
main point
of our growing
that we understood what we have to do
not only create the project we have to
get a communication with the final
clients we hired a good team
they did a big marketing strategy and we
understood that we have to be present
not only online as uh the same as
offline in a close future before the end
of this year we are planning to
be present offline in united states
[Music]
we can make a cooperation with the
foreign companies we are
doing the branding of our backpacks for
uh
international i.t companies or transport
companies and it's part of cooperation
if we are talking in this way yes it's
really good if we are talking about that
investigation from the foreigner
companies it's
also really good it helps us to be
much better than we
are right now
the investors has to understand that if
the
products made in ukraine is really good
and
if these products
made with the with passion with the
really good quality
this product was checked
it's not a problem to invest what we
have to do
just just to spread these ideas
as much as we can
plural for me it's firstly people
i really like to work with the
really really good people who has a
passion who
get a really good vision who believes in
his products
i'm sure 400 percent that
we are honest to all to our own that we
are doing really good and responsible
for the products
it is what it is uru is part of my life
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
you